jeder zweite dass gerade sie den skandal
wenn von einem kanal also klick unter
dem video auf abonnieren
allerdings darf ich euch heute herzlich
willkommen heißen zu einer neuen episode
whatsapp fans mit luca und ich würde
sagen wir fangen mit einem mädchen
dessen freund irgendwie sauer auf sie
ist und deswegen schreibt sie ihrer
freundin er ist glaubt mir wegen punkt
was sauer vielleicht wegen deiner
grammatik ja denn die diese leute die
sich einfach um grammatikalische richtig
sprachen lernen da die falls du zur
u-bahn kommst ich bin gerade
jungfernheide
alles klar also schreiben muss wirklich
gelernt sein ich hab voll bock auf
bürger was hast du für probleme burger
king
es ist heute die episode wurde
deutsche sprache schwere sprache das
nächste foto zeigt den verlauf von einem
jungen mit seiner mutter und zwar
schreibt seine mutter am 25 mehr als
zehn minuten zehn minuten später
schreibt sich nochmal essen
vier tage später am 29 märz schreibt sie
essen und er antwortet ja und dann
schreibt sie nochmal am 30 märz essen am
freitag essen am montag essen und
gestern essen
durch die familiengruppe auch immer
dafür genutzt dass mama schreibt vance
essen gibt die nächste nachricht kommt
wieder von einer mutter und zwar
schreibt sie ihrer tochter kannst du von
unterwegs erdbeeren mitbringen am
dritten juni und dann einige tage später
schreibt sie bin am see wüsste nicht
woher mutter was ist mit dir die
nachricht hast du selbst geschrieben
ja bitte hallt
verläuft mit der mutter sind kommen
jetzt zu dieser nachricht du hast dein
telefon auf dem küchentisch liegen
gelassen sehr gut mama danke für die
info hallo oma deine erste sms wie ist
das neue handy lieber max grün aber
schon wie ich wirke kleine tasten ich
hoffe es geht hier gut viele grüße deine
oma ps ich liebe dich okay aber schreib
mir keine langen briefe wie du es vor
100 jahren gemacht hast kurzmitteilungen
oma fasst sich so kurz wie möglich um so
weniger geht auch schief mit deinen
wurst fingerchen zb lg in klammern liebt
dich und die unbeantwortet hdf
hat europa ein handy bzw
chris meyer hatte das nicht kann ich
morgen kommen muss um 20.14 zumal auch
hier alles gut gesund und so weiter die
sonne ist für hier wenn ihr kommt mama
geht es gut fahren morgen hin wir haben
unsere hütte gestrichen sieht aus wie
bullerbü genießt eure letzten tage
liegen
mama profi was
was
was ich habe kein einziges wort
ehrlich gesagt war es gestern aber
wieder total reizvoll danke fand mich
auch ziemlich nett stoppt das war nicht
so gemeint
trotz voll autokorrektur ist zu nett zu
dir
kennt ihr das wenn ihr einen ford
richtig schreibt die autokorrektur denkt
aber dass ihr ein anderes wort meint da
fühle ich mich auch jetzt so veräppelt
hast du frei habe ich habe da eine tüte
bombe aufgegessen bringen dir bitte eine
neue mit danke und mir eine tüte salons
ja das heißt die person hat einerseits
die bomben von der andere person
aufgegessen schreibt der anderen person
jetzt ja ich habe leider von dir
aufgegessen also kaufte eine neue ton
bringen mir bitte auf was mit
du bist auf jeden fall die freundin des
jahres hallo mama hast du einen schönen
tag
ja
mütter halten ihr schreibt die biene
eigentlich wollte ich was von marius
aber den erreiche ich nicht mehr geht
auch im moment nicht er hat gerade
versehentlich seine siamkatze
zerschnitten und ärgert sich jetzt total
marius hat eine katze hh super
autokorrektur hat die falsche sim-karte
zerschnitten hh
ich habe auch eine sim-karte schnitten
spielen
gerne petitjean videos allerdings gerade
schon bei französisch sind meine lieben
freunde habe ich uns für die heutige
wieso auch einen französischen whatsapp
fälle vorbereitet vielleicht könnt ihr
den hier in den kommentaren übersetzen
ich hatte latein bis ins aber ich hatte
kein französisch von daher entschuldige
bitte meine aussprache aber eine person
schreibt die nachricht die review ktm
chinesische thema demokratie die minen
die rheydter city
der letzte satz heißt ich liebe
österreich hat und sonst wie warum
zweifeln die leute trotz einem iq von
124 immer noch an meiner intelligenz
weil du intelligenz falsch schreibst und
da wenn freunde ich will meine frage an
euch kennt ihr diese leute die sich
unnormal was auf ihren abiturschnitt
oder auf ihren allgemeinen notenschnitt
ein bild und deswegen meinen sie seien
wie brains des jahres hatte sie auch
solche leute auf eurer schule oder habt
ihr immer noch solche deutet auf eurer
schule
ich finde so unangenehm werden
das ist super dass ich genau beim thema
intelligenz keinen vernünftigen satz
raus bringen kann
naja ich glaube ihr wisst was ich meine
leute die einfach denken ja um einen
notenschnitt sagt das über meine
intelligenz aus dem notenschnitt sagt
einfach nur aus dass du halt ich habe
gerade den lach flash des todes warum
das mir war extrem langweilig also habe
ich ein bisschen in der bibel gelesen
die zu hause rum lag plötzlich kommt
mein vater rhein sieht mich und schreit
spiele haben jesus stirbt a ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha wer liest die bibel wenn
einem langweilig ist otto grad in der
ganzen ist die home zeitung ja ich bin
mir seite 703
[Musik]
ich mache jetzt goethe eier gefüllt ohne
gott jahre kennt nicht die goethe meyer
zeigt sich von diesem paket sei der
nächste nachricht wenn eine person
gefragt wie es ihr geht und sie
antwortet ganz gemischt und dir das kind
nicht so schön ich dachte gestern dass
ich dich gerne mal wieder in den
abnehmen würde
aber der zug ist ja scheinbar abgefahren
wollen wir uns trotzdem mal wieder zum
kaffee oder ähnlichen treffen arm in den
haben neben oh gott ich bin aufgestanden
jahr erkennt nicht wenn man jemand lange
nicht gesehen hat immer wieder schön in
den abkommen wir allerdings wieder zu
einer richtigen mutter nachricht und
zwar dieser hier
du hast gerade ein glücksschwein
bekommen das hilft aber nur wenn man es
weiter gibt
warum sind alle eltern so und auch
gerade diese ganzen sachen die rom
geschickt werden zum beispiel bei uns in
den ganzen eltern whatsapp gruppen und
so werden die ganze zeit zu acht
de/audio tondateien rom geschickt oder
auch diese ganzen komischen update zur
jetzigen situation schicken wir auch
immer eltern tausendfach rum in alle
möglichen gruppen ist das brauche ich
auch so alt da das hier ist der nächste
wort fällt und zwar unterhalten sich
jetzt zwei freundinnen über einen typen
dass eine medien schreibt aber er hat
sicher innere werte und daraufhin
schreibt ihre freundin ja schlechte
leberwürste auf jeden fall
sie schreibt diesem verdutzten im
leberwerte hahahahaha ich liegt flach
ich auch zu gut aha
hier schreibt die liebe elisabeth dass
sie single ist und eine freundin von ihr
schreibt vielleicht liest es die nsa mit
und leitet es an single boys weiter
hallo liebe nsa falls sie das mittel ist
sendet es bitte an single jungs weiter
wer voll nett zu als weihnachtsgeschenk
und so und damit ihr es auf jeden fall
ist hier noch ein paar wörter und dann
hat sie halt ein paar wörter
reingeschrieben wo die eventuelle
hellhörig werden könnte die kann ich
euch allerdings im video nicht zeigen
hier fragt ein junge seine freundin hey
wie sieht's aus wird heute abend und
seine freundin antwortet ja keine ahnung
sollen wir uns einfach in kamel stute
treffen karlsruhe ich meine karlsruhe
haha ja die autokorrektur mal wieder
etwas besser unterwegs hier habt ihr die
autokorrektur eigentlich an
auf eurem handy weil alle meine freunde
haben die halt an und ich habe dir halt
aus weil ich das einfach komplett
aufregt und was mich auch aufregt sind
solche nachrichten und die kommen auch
in 99 von 100 prozent der fälle von
irgendwelchen über 40 jährigen die die
gerade die gerade images für sich
entdecken damit menschen gesehen
ziemlich abgestoßen ich stehe im moment
voll auf diese orientalischen schlabber
okay ich meine schlabberhosen ja meine
lieben freundlich dabei ihr könnt euch
alle denken was sich da gerade zensiert
und ausgeübt habe
richtig käsekuchen bist du morgen auch
dabei meine fähigkeiten werden an einem
anderen ort benötigt maras auf
fähigkeiten
ja die autokorrektur meine lieben
freunde kennen sie kommen allerdings
auch schon zum letzten cent fürs heutige
video und zwar fragt eine person in
liebenthal ex deine eltern kommen doch
aus polen oder kannst du polnisch job
wie so was heißt autoschlüssel auf
polnisch brechstange und an der stelle
wird das heute wieder jetzt allerdings
wieder beende meine lieben freunde wenn
es euch gefallen hat dann das gerne
einen daumen hoch unter dem video hier
da und hier ist ein smiley eingeblendet
wenn ihr darauf könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren würde ich euch wärmstens
empfehlen weil ich jeden tag und super
beschissen das video hochladen und hier
ist ein anderes super beschissenes video
verlinkt
wirklich da drauf darauf abonnieren
danach können wir noch ein video
anschauen weil wir haben alle gerade
ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig zu tun